so a lot of people have asked me why I
haven't yet covered gun control to be
honest I'm just not that much of a gun
enthusiast I really only own the one
well unless you count my rifle or my
backup or my collector's item
traditional colt 45 replicas to be fair
I haven't fired this thing in weeks I
think I'm a few blocks around but those
are technically my mom's good old Barack
Obama has said he wants to make the
assault weapons ban permanent he
describes the weapons within the van as
machine guns it only belong in a foreign
battlefield
well Barack that statement is about as
accurate as the final cut of a Michael
Moore interview we're about to do an
interview here with a gun owner and
bought there he is there he is let's go
get it sir could I grab just a minute of
your time sir clay Beck what do you want
lumpy right sir do you own a gun here in
this household you know I own a gun and
why is that because I care about my
family and I figure if I'm a rapist or a
murderer
I'm gonna biggest deterrent to be going
in that house is somebody having a gun
get out of my way all right sir thank
you for you can we edit that I'm a
rapist you know I own a gun sir sir if I
could grab just one minute of your time
sir just
sure if I could just oh crap truth is
most of the guns on this ban list are
nothing more than your trusty old
semi-automatic and for those sissies who
don't know nearly every handgun nowadays
is a semi-automatic this is just another
part of the Obama administration's
multi-pronged approach to take away our
Second Amendment rights and they're not
the first plenty of successful leaders
have implemented gun control in the past
Hitler Stalin Che Guevara and now we've
got Pelosi and pals I feel bad even
mentioning her name in the same sentence
at least the others had charm or Talent
truth is when the government's goal is
tyranny the last thing they want is an
armed populace and no not all Second
Amendment supporters or survivalist nut
jobs though Ted Nugent is funny
among the many misdeeds of British rule
in India history will look upon the act
of depriving a whole nation of arms as
the blackest spoken by Gandhi folks
ouch liberals how does it feel to see
your pacifist idols supporting our right
to bear arms and betting is as painful
as Michael Moore's realization that
nobody wants to see his movies anymore
how important is your freedom to you
with today's government folks you need
to take a stand and start fighting for
your rights and remember we've already
got a leg up because when it comes to a
difference of opinion the guy with the
gun wins and to those of you who support
these motions and still want to take our
guns away well to you I say go ahead
make my day